what do you think about the uh about the
concept of whiteness
i don't know what the purpose of it is
and so yeah there there there are some
white people and there is um
there is disproportionate power
there is a sense of entitlement that a
certain kind of white person has a
certain naivete
sure that's there from the world
historical perspective
white people these northern and western
european people have had a
disproportionate and in many ways
grievous impact upon
the world certainly the question is
whether here in 2021 with all those
things having happened the solution to
that is some grand revolution in our
psychosocial consciousness right now is
that really what we need or
can we have a more meat and potatoes
aspect to things and help people who
need help live in the society which for
better or for worse these white people
largely created when they started
getting in ships and sailing across the
ocean and i think for a lot of people
there's a sense that somehow there needs
to be some reckoning i wonder if they
wish we would all go back to living in
bands of two or three hundred people by
the sides of the river i mean that seems
to be what they want
unfortunately modernity developed
through the
actions and machinations and ravagings
and rapings and pillagings of a certain
kind of white person advantaged by the
geography of a peninsula called europe
that happened but here we are now and
there's so many things that we have to
do
so i think that yeah there is a such
thing as whiteness but the question is
whether we need to de-center it to the
way that we're talking about and to the
to the degree that people are talking
about de-centering whiteness and if we
completely de-center whiteness the
question is what have we got and is that
really a world that we want maybe we
just need to go back to the way we were
thinking about these things about 20
years ago where the idea was everything
white is not good a great many things
that are not white or good and let's
make sure that we pay as much attention
as we can to everything that isn't white
because whiteness is not all that's good
the new idea that you decenter whiteness
and stigmatize it and pretend for
example that music theory is white
that's kabuki
or perhaps with more respect that's
religious fervor that's not making sense
of things or turning up on time or the
nuclear family or grit and determination
or precision right yeah yeah like those
things
that to me was one of the most
disturbing things to
see
especially when it got demonized uh to
as something that the black community
shouldn't aspire to
as values
which no one should aspire to and that
the solution for is not to play the game
well but to rearrange the rules of the
game so that people who don't play that
game well can play it badly and still
win
that to me
is so pernicious it's like
turning up on time
for a thing
is required throughout the rest of your
life whether that's a doctor but you've
got a doctor's appointment you have an
important surgery and you rock up two
hours late and the surgeon's on to
somebody else and you want to complain
about the fact that that's structurally
whiteness and i don't adhere to your
concept of what being on time is
or rules when you look when you roll the
clock forward to do with levels of
poverty black boys and black girls
growing up without a father in the
family like nuclear family it's one of
the core central supporting structures
that having a good childhood that forms
a robust and effective adulthood is
built on top of it actually feels to me
like
the sort of thing that you would slip
below the surface if you wanted to make
black people fail
yep
all of that stuff sounds like something
some white supremacist in 1895
would come up with and promulgate and
then we could look back at that person
now and talk about what a monster they
were on yet here's all this stuff i
think that once the religion comes into
it also in that
what you're saying is clearly not an
opinion that's just logic anybody
understands that the idea that to be
precise is white
the only thing you can get out of that
whole idea
that precision
that making deductions and inductions
thinking about results etc that all of
this is white
is roughly that black people are
supposed to just i swear this is what
people are thinking black people are
supposed to jam and dance
and have raggedy conversations where we
intuit one another's feelings
and reason
that's frankly that's what it sounds
like like what are we gonna do dance you
know if we're not gonna do real physics
i think we're supposed to just dance and
once again that sounds like you do dance
better than white people though
that frankly that is true and i think a
lot of them are thinking that you know
they don't move as well no so we're
gonna do what we do which is jam but
jamming wouldn't have created the world
that we sit here saying those things in
and you know getting listened to so it's
just
none of it makes sense and that's why
i'm saying that all of this is a creed
rather than something anybody's thought
out what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace